I wanted a cappuccino and they have like
[__] 19 Starbucks in there and I
don't drink that [__] [__] it's
absolute [__] they don't give a [__]
about you you know where those beans
come from mainland China
I know what you guys are up to you're
trying to take us out you know that we
love coffee huh
we over there [__] with your
dumplings I don't think we are good
anything other than a Starbucks and
they're like we have a French Bistro
around I actually believed that there
was a French Bistro right and I go there
and it's like little caffeine
creme Cafe and she grabs this giant
[__] cup it's like this big and I'm
like oh no this is gonna what is that
what is that a Big Gulp cappuccino
supposed to be this big you know pull
out the
Duke up and I see the lady making it
she's just not even looking
just it was terrible and I [__] threw
it out